le gabon voir quelle est l'ambiance
actuellement pour cette manifestation
eh bien ces manifestants ils viennent de
se rassembler sur la place de la nation
principalement des gilet jaune pour une
marche des libertés puisque ils sont
insatisfaits de la pelle statique à
manifester contre la loi sécurité
globale qui a lieu en ce moment même à
la place de la république et je me
trouve avec jérôme rodriguez gilet jaune
bonjour jérôme rodriguez pouvez vous
m'expliquer alors pourquoi cet appel à
manifester séparés parce que pas mal de
gens étaient mécontents de n'avoir
qu'une seule statique pour une marge de
liberté c'était assez paradoxal donc de
pouvoir permettre de marcher de nation
jusqu'à république de voir rejoindre
notre manifeste
l'autre manifestation donc on se
complète quelque part et les gens qui
sont désireux de pouvoir échanger tout
en criant leur colère et leur révolte
tout en marchant on leur offre cette
possibilité là aujourd'hui donc c'est
pas vraiment un clivage entre vous c'est
juste un désaccord sur la forme à
prendre sur cet essai plus voilà sur
l'organisation de la manifestation après
des accords faudrait peut-être que des
gens n'arrivent à à pouvoir communiquer
ensemble les uns les autres à c'est ce
qui fait aussi l'objet de l'ensemble des
manifestations c'est de pouvoir s'unir
donc on va créer l'union pour on allait
les rejoindre
maintenant le message est le même les
revendications sont les mêmes mois
j'appuierai que cette manifestation
aussi renforce ce que nous on revendique
depuis deux ans aujourd'hui c'est à dire
plus de justice sociale et fiscale le
mieux vivre et un changement total de la
politique de mâcon aujourd'hui voir sa
démission si possible avec tout ce qu'on
a pu
puisqu'on a pu tout ce qu'on a pu subir
au cours de ces deux ans donc on garde
le même message et on complète le
message aujourd'hui de 2 de la fin de
toutes ces lois liberticides au jour de
mise en place est ce qu'il ya une
priorité ce que vous voulez avoir de la
loi sécurité globale de la loi sur les
séparatismes ou c toutes ensemble le
problème c'est que nous les jeunes on
est confronté à ce genre de lois
liberticides déjà depuis deux ans je
veux dire quand on reprend la loi de la
première loi de sécurité mises en place
par castaner déjà ne serait-ce que nous
il est jaune on est un petit peu
aujourd'hui ennuyés parce que on est
censé ne pas porter de masque aux
manifestations mais on nous oblige
aujourd'hui porter un masque pantois ses
lois
ces lois aujourd'hui de sécurité ces
lois liberticides on en subit les frais
depuis deux ans nous gilet jaune
donc une fois de plus une loi de moi
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que ces
lois commence à toucher de l'ensemble
des français donc on est responsable
mais surtout responsable d'avoir mis au
grand jour les désirs politique de
macron de de fermer la bouche à
l'ensemble du peuple et de faire en
sorte qu'ils se soumettent à sa
politique que tout le monde ne veut plus
aujourd'hui quoi merci beaucoup et cette
manifestation maintenant elle va se
diriger vers la place de la république
où l'appel à manifester est tout autre
puisque là il y aura des scènes vivantes
des prises de parole notamment avec des
artistes et les travailleurs du
spectacle qui se retrouvent au chômage
technique pour cause d'eux que 8,19 à
lutter merci à pour toutes ces
précisions se retrouvent lors d'un autre
prochaine édition